oh yeah
this is the original all right I cannot
believe it man I have not driven one of
these in a while
in 2007 Disney Hall arrival of Tony
Stark at this event that he then leaves
and goes on his first mission
so downtown the architecture of Disney
Hall and the emergence of this rebirth
of cool with the Audi brand and I just
remember thinking man the synergy of
marvel and Audi and the way that it
panned out it's just incredible and then
the success of the film and it's like
these two brands built off each other
and it's been a love affair ever since
and now the e-tron GT which promises to
be the most exciting electric vehicle in
history and we're gonna we're gonna get
a glimpse at that and I'm gonna talk to
the guy pick is teutonic brain oh there
you are hey Mark what's up buddy I wrote
it
can I yeah great to see you what are you
doing it's catching everything
ever since car starts with the sketch
right it's beginning incredible I have a
challenge for you I would like you for
you to join me in the e sauna and we're
just gonna sit there silently and see
who can take it for longer it's very
well lit well yeah I can just feel the
infrared energy of creativity in here
all right I can't take any more will you
show me the real thing sure come on such
a pleasure did we continue put her there
pal that's the one that's
it seems really intuitive and this and
really supportive you know I need to
drive it right well I mean I asked Tony
Stark in Avengers 4 out in theaters
spring 2019 I did but this is us nobody
that looks like on that looks like that
hey everybody it's Charlie I got a lot
of requests to do a video for this new
Avengers end game
outtie commercial that Robert Downey jr.
did so this is just part of the larger
integration that Marvel does with Audi
going back to the first Iron Man film so
he does this for most of the big movies
that he's featured in because that you
know out II did the integration with
Marvel originally so they signed a
long-term deal so ODB came Iron Man's
car so every time Iron Man would appear
in a new movie with the brand-new car
that Audi wanted to hype up they would
do some special feature at like this but
there's also some questions about him
driving the new eat Ron during Avengers
4 because the last we saw him in the
trailer he was stuck in outer space with
nebula on the Guardian ship
so no worries we'll break it down and
there's a new round of that IMAX ticket
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave your favorite
Marvel commercial like this on the video
like your favorite funny ad they did one
with Tom Holland back during spider-man
homecoming like a special ad hyping up
outie but because it was homecoming and
he was 16 they used a driver's exam to
do that but that's basically what it was
it was an Audi ad for their brand new
car spider-man Steel's flash Thompson's
car later in the movie it's an Audi TT
happy hogan drives an Audi a8 and they
like feature a couple big shots of their
dashboard and some of the systems so
it's a low grade ad for their car that
features what it can do in an exchange
for that Marvel gets access to as many
Audi's as it wants to blow up like
during Civil War when Black Panther was
running down Winter Soldier and they
chased through the tunnel and blow up
all those Audi's so Robert Downey jr.
says that Tony Stark drives an Audi
e-tron during endgame why did he stop
driving the r8 that probably has
something to do with survivor's guilt
in how he changes after the snapping the
whole thing about Thanos is he felt like
the universe's population was growing
too fast
and everyone was overusing their planet
two resources so his solution was to get
rid of half of all life and then the
people that survived could just go on
with their lives like they were before
just doing the exact same things Ironman
is supposed to be one of the more
forward-thinking Avengers he created a
new element to generate insane amounts
of clean energy in a really efficient
way so in a very Elan musk way it's only
a matter of time before he would see him
trying to integrate that technology into
all of stark tech why wouldn't Tony
start trying to develop a line of
technology that consumers could buy
based on his arc reactor technology
electric cars electric homes all this
clean free energy available to the world
that feels like the direction that he
would go and we don't know exactly what
he's going to be like when he gets back
but we do know that he is completely
broken so I have a feeling that when the
car is featured in the movie with Tony
Stark yes it's in the future after he
gets back so it's probably just a really
short upbeat moment in the film so even
though he's really broken I think the
thing that will catalyze him is when
ant-man shows up with the quantum
technology and they start to figure out
a plan for how to save the universe so
even though everyone feels like Thor
looks guilt ridden and really pissed off
obviously that's not gonna last for the
entire film because that would be a huge
bummer so that's why I think all that
trailer footage that they presented for
us is just from the first little bit of
the film before they figure out what's
going on like cap says I don't know what
I'm gonna do if this doesn't work their
plan to use quantum energy will probably
start working and that's when the film's
pace will start to pick up so the other
big question though then is as how does
Tony Stark get back to Planet Earth I've
seen a couple new theories since the
trailers been out for a couple weeks and
I've seen a lot of you have questions
about what's going on with Pepper Potts
in her rescue armor so I'll say this I
don't like the theory about Pepper Potts
rescuing Tony just because he is in deep
deep space in Pepper Potts does not have
better technology than what Tony has
right now Tony Stark Iron Man always has
the most advanced version of whatever
new generation of armor there is so I
don't think that his problem being stuck
in outer space with no fuel and no food
is a problem that's going to be solved
with Pepper Potts technology we do know
that she actually wears armor during the
film because we saw her pose
this picture so she has a blue looking
suit of armor but I think that's only
going to appear during a very brief part
of the film where she'll be completely
CG because she'll have the helmet on so
you see a combination of Gwyneth Paltrow
doing the HUD style shots where you're
just seeing her face lit up by the
monitor screen right in front of her
she'll be in the middle of some chaotic
giant battle scene and she'll be
rescuing a lot of regular people so like
she will get a really big hero moment
but it'll be very brief she'll probably
only be using the armor on screen for a
couple minutes at best as far as Iron
Man making it back to Planet Earth with
nebula I still think that it's a
combination of him just using that crazy
genius brain to MacGyver himself out of
that situation but with a little help
from nebula and Captain Marvel who just
happens to be nearby in outer space the
other funny comments that I've seen
recently too is it what about Wong
because Wong has most of the same
abilities as Doctor Strange he's not
quite as powerful and he doesn't have
the eye of agamotto but because right
now he's the de facto guardian of the
New York sanctum
he's like the person that the Avengers
could go to who's nearby who could help
them with things like this is the same
thing with Thor Stormbreaker and his
ability to open the Bifrost they
probably just have a hard time
pinpointing where Iron Man is if you had
Heimdall and you knew where he was it'd
be relatively easy to open a Bifrost to
just go pick him up and bring him right
back
what a coincidence that we lose Heimdall
right before one of our major Avengers
gets lost in outer space I suppose you
could also say that Wong's power only
goes so far like he could not open a
wormhole to say likes a car which is on
the other end of the universe so I know
a lot of you have also started asking
about the doctor's train sequel which
they finally confirmed scott derrickson
is coming back but they don't have a
screenwriter yet so we don't know
exactly when that movie's gonna drop but
it's looking like May 2021 so we're
still a couple years away don't worry
I'll do more videos about phase four
movies when they start to make more
announcements but let me know in the
comments how do you think that Iron Man
gets back to Planet Earth there's a
whole bunch of new stuff that just
dropped there might be a Dark Crystal
trailer tomorrow if you're a big fan of
the Dark Crystal so I'll try to get
videos out for everything I'll name a
new giveaway winner when I post new
Marvel 2 click here to rewatch the
avengers endgame trailer billion
times and click here for a brand new
Game of Thrones season 8 promo
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]